I'm just taking it all in it's my first
Oscars
it's about her she's presenting tonight
and she's trying to stay out of the way
he's been so great make sure no was on
my train he's making sure everything is
in place is something today this morning
we did first thing you did he went to
the store and got all this fruit and
croissants and vegetables and we're to
Starbucks and got it like the big old
container for everybody he fed the whole
glam team you're a good man good
positive energy from the start you
actually posted a photo of your outfit
from x-man let's take a look at it right
now right here how difficult is it
getting into that costume it takes like
two women to just die and grease me up
and pull it up and it's an it's a
process for sure but actually really I
like the way it feels I feel very
powerful in it did you say grease you up
yeah he actually had to put baby oil
lubricant that they have to put on it
it's a big that's one big latex suit so
yeah it's a family show it's a family
show
grease grease right